the idea of using data for analysis and
statistical analysis is pervasive it's
it's everywhere now so there's quite a
bit of excitement about the topic and we
will have students at a very young age
now contact our department and ask about
majoring in statistics this did not
happen 10-15 years ago with respect to
the Carnegie Mellon programs in
particular the curriculum is designed to
give students a taste and experience of
what it would be like to do statistics
and data science in the real world and
as such we take problems that are real
interdisciplinary research problems
industry problems and government
problems from all over and we put them
straight into the classroom so it's we
don't actually use a lot of textbooks
after the introductory level we also
incorporate research almost at all the
levels it's possible to be a freshman
and work on a research project you don't
have to wait to be a senior which is the
case that quite a few universities we're
very supportive of clubs that have to do
with statistics there's a data science
club there's a sports analytics Club we
have an actuarial one we have finance
groups there are several different ways
you can major in statistics at Carnegie
Mellon what makes statistics and data
science as a field extremely exciting
and inclusive it is an extremely
inclusive field is that you can be
successful coming from a wide variety of
backgrounds you do not have to have
amazing coding or computer programming
experience when you start you do not
have to have amazing mathematical
experience or background when you start
there's not one type of student that can
be successful in statistics and data
science there are students who will work
on mostly theoretical problems there are
students who want to work more on
algorithms there are students who want
to work in psychology infant development
learning labs there are students who
want to work on sports so we get a very
diverse set of backgrounds with all of
our students and then our programs are
flexible to reflect that